me dan este triángulo abc que parece ser
rectángulo de hecho lo es si se fijan 3
al cuadrado más 4 al cuadrado sería 25
que es 5 al cuadrado como obedece el
teorema de pitágoras este ángulo de aquí
debe ser un ángulo recto y me piden
evaluar el coseno de dos veces el ángulo
abc que es justamente este ángulo de
aquí quiero encontrar el coseno de dos
veces este ángulo y esto no lo puede
evaluar directamente ahora pero lo que
sí puedo hacer es encontrar cuánto vale
el coseno del coseno del ángulo a bs
sencillamente porque por definición en
un triángulo rectángulo el coseno del
ángulo a veces sería el cateto adyacente
entre la hipotenusa que en este caso el
cateto adyacente vale 3 y la hipotenusa
vale 5 así que el coseno del ángulo a
veces vale 3 quintos también puede
encontrar el valor del seno del ángulo
abc el seno del ángulo a veces sería el
cateto opuesto entre la hipotenusa que
en este caso vale 4
entre 5 así que bien si puede encontrar
una fórmula para el coseno de dos veces
el ángulo a veces que sólo involucra al
coseno de abc y al seno de abc entonces
ya habré acabado y si recuerdan si
recuerdan de los demás vídeos de
trigonometría dicha fórmula existe
recuerden que el coseno de dos veces un
ángulo teta es igual a quien al coseno
al cuadrado de teta menos el seno al
cuadrado de teta ahora bien si
sustituyen si sustituyen teta por abc
obtendrían que el coseno el co seno de
dos veces el ángulo abc
va a ser igual a el coseno al cuadrado
del ángulo abc
- el seno al cuadrado del ángulo abc
pero conocemos cuánto vale el coseno del
ángulo abc y el seno del ángulo abc
el coseno del ángulo abc
el co seno del ángulo abc
vale tres quintos así que el coste no al
cuadrado del ángulo a veces sería tres
quintos al cuadrado y que hay del seno
del ángulo abc pues eso vimos que vale
cuatro quintos así que el seno al
cuadrado del ángulo abc valdría cuatro
quintos al cuadrado esencialmente lo que
estamos buscando es esta diferencia pero
cuánto vale eso pues tres quintos al
cuadrado es 9 entre 25 menos cuatro
quintos al cuadrado es 16 entre 25 9
menos 16 sería menos 7
y el denominador es común así que la
respuesta al problema es que es el
coseno de dos veces el ángulo a veces
vale menos 7 entre 25 y esto tiene
sentido porque recuerden si si
recordamos cómo definimos las funciones
trigonométricas en el círculo unitario
el coche no era la coordenada x que
correspondía
el ángulo en el círculo unitario es
decir si estoy aquí es mi círculo
unitario entonces el ángulo abc quedaría
más o menos por ahí y entonces su
coordenada x sería positiva este sería
el ángulo abc al duplicar este ángulo
digamos llegaría por acá y ahora la
coordenada x del ángulo es negativa y
por eso este coseno salió negativo a
pesar de que estos dos fueran positivos